well we had quite a little surprise
yesterday from the FBI and FBI director
James Comey who decided to release 15
year old documents related to former
President Bill Clinton just you know a
week before his wife Bill Clinton's wife
that is stands for election in the
presidential election of the United
States and the the original critique of
James Comey was you know that original
press conference where he said there
were not going to be charges against
Hillary Clinton that probably didn't
make sense the FBI regularly does
investigations that don't lead to
charges why was there any conference at
all and then there was criticism when
more recently FBI director James Comey
wrote a letter saying you know we've
uncovered some more emails based on an
investigation into anthony Weiner's
computer and now we're going to see
whether there's any relationship there
to hillary clinton classified emails
etcetera he was slammed for that saying
again why me even make that statement
we're not going to know anything about
it before Tuesday's election just wait
and let us know if your investigation
turns anything up and now the FBI has
released a hundred and twenty nine pages
of documents related to an investigation
closed with no charges in 2005 into
President Bill Clinton's pardon of Marc
Rich now to jog your memory Marc Rich
had been married to a wealthy Democratic
donor and was the subject of a whole
bunch of publicity impress and and this
pardon and so much more this file was
posted online Monday but there was
really no attention paid to it and that
until the FBI went out yesterday and
actually sent a tweet saying hey we
release this stuff yesterday now
officially the up odd timing just days
before the presidential election was
because there was a FOIA request filed
Freedom of Information Act request which
was completed and then posted under
standard FBI practice that's according
to one law enforcement official the
weird thing is as the Clinton campaign
pointed out the timing is very very odd
why all of a sudden is this getting
posted and
even more unusual is that they didn't
just post the documents they posted on
Twitter announcing that they posted the
documents the FBI's Twitter account for
public records announcements was dormant
until the FBI decided to mention hey by
the way we posted these documents why
all of a sudden does the Twitter account
go active right before documents about
Bill Clinton are released right before
Hillary Clinton's presidential election
an FBI official says oh the software was
restarted because of a software update
isn't this all awfully convenient guys
just a few days before this election
yeah i mean the FBI before was facing
criticism for doing the bidding of the
obama administration yeah and choosing
not to recommend charges against Hillary
Clinton back in July I mean you can't
possibly make that argument now no doubt
about it and Rachel you know I started
thinking what could be going on here and
one possibility I thought of was did
somebody get to James Comey maybe he
realized that after what happened with
the with the entire investigation and
then this letter that he wrote maybe he
keep somebody got to him and said you
know you're out if Hillary wins so maybe
he would he would be well that would be
a good idea to do something to help
Donald Trump but it just seems so
simplistic I don't know about all of the
kind of conspiracy theories that they've
gotten to comee and things of that
nature but kind of more on what the note
of what Pat was saying is that I feel
like in the very beginning his kind of
unusual transparency about his reasons
for non prosecution were kind of because
he was worried about the public
perception that the Attorney General and
Obama were kind of tainted on the matter
and that was going to kind of compromise
the results however now I kind of think
that if Hillary does end up winning he
will avoid he'll be saved from kind of
the whole tainted nature of it will he
though because I I I think it could also
lead to some pretty awkward situations
where if Hillary Clinton is elected the
next president of the United States and
James commis actions are perceived as
political which they are and
particularly in a way that seems to be
specifically harmful to hell
McClinton couldn't that just create an
absolutely disastrous working
relationship between a clinton white
house and then FBI that could be
perceived as having tried to prevent the
election of Hillary Clinton right but if
he waited until after than he would be
accused of playing politics by having
deliberately waited it so that Hillary
wins and then he says that their stuff
in the emails exactly so we're how can
you win in this situation there's
probably Pat a pro Clinton faction in
the FBI and either I don't know if it
would be an anti Clinton or a pro Trump
faction and maybe James Comey is sort of
stuck in the middle and the idea was hey
you know what I did something that was
good for Hillary Clinton by saying no
prosecution and then I did two things
that are bad for Hillary Clinton days
before the election maybe he's trying to
say hey I'm good I I did something good
for for both of them right and that's
his idea of being impartial right doing
something negative to both sides of the
equation I mean the FBI has a history of
being overly political we saw that with
j edgar Hoover and definitely we don't
have to go back to that yet but yeah but
with each uh at each disclosure kind of
necessitates another disclosure and
they're getting further and further away
from the norm which is to stay out of
political affairs I know that this might
be crazy but what if the FBI only
comments when there's actually an
investigation that is leading to charges
or a recommendation of charges and stops
commenting on non events I know that
that might be a little crazy but now
that you I think you're right Rachel he
necessitates or at least creates the
feeling that he needs to do more with
each successive announcement or letter
declaration